invalorant you can pretty much win any
round gun rounds half eyes ecos all of
them they are all
perfectly winnable but compared to
Counter-Strike there are far fewer
rounds that are guaranteed and a big
part of that is that unlike NCS no
single gun is King but TN you could make
a very quick rotation back into mid if
he wanted
what one versus three there is
a Time concern here so there it is
there's a snake bite can he stop this
it's a save bike gonna be enough it is
going to deny this one for now and there
goes the classic
so why is it that even the worst guns in
valorent are still kind of good is that
a bad thing and does it lower the game's
skill ceiling or does it actually make
things that much more exciting he can
stick it half all the way just needs to
watch the angles what let's get a double
kill with a shorty
valorent has always been compared to
Counter-Strike we've been doing it for
three years now and it is undeniable
that valorent and CS do share some
crucial similarities at their core
they're both 5v5 tactical Shooters with
economy systems and most of valorence
weapons are direct copies of Cs goes but
aside from that they're actually not as
alike as some people might think
ballerant wasn't designed for hardcore
FPS Boomers instead Riot wanted to make
a game that was more accessible for
someone who was just getting into the
genre incorporating unique agent
abilities into the gameplay and allowing
both attackers and Defenders to use the
entire arsenal of weapons another
important distinction is that
counter-strike's economy is a lot less
forgiving than balance saving weapons is
much more common in CS because it takes
longer to hit Max loss bonus plus it's
first to 16 instead of 13. now you might
remember that these were some of the
things that we covered when we talked
about valorin's economy last year but we
didn't delve that deeply into how some
of the games more Niche weapons can
impact games you see in Counter-Strike
there's sort of just a small fixed set
of weapons that the vast majority of
serious competitive players will
actually spend their money on rifles
like the AK M4 Famas and Galil are
common options alongside the op and the
occasional deagle or five seven or Tech
9 on eco Rams there are of course
players who make SMGs and czs sing but
most rely on rifles or Ops to gain an
edge over their opponents of course
teams will still occasionally get ecoed
but it doesn't really happen that often
especially if one of those teams is on
an actual full safe we saw some
absolutely filthy Eagle plays throughout
the champion stage of the Paris major
but those still didn't usually result in
round wins in fact teams attempted a
combined total of 103 Eco and semi-eco
rounds which accounts for Rounds where
they spent less than ten thousand
dollars and they only managed to win
eight rounds total throughout all seven
matches in the champion stage that's
only eight percent rounded up and when
we compare this to valorant
things get pretty interesting Valor and
players do still opt to buy rifles but
on eco rounds anything goes and it's
been like that since the day the game
came out oh Dead He's managed to
actually find himself a crack and steal
with the Bucky causing problems this
isn't supposed to be happening right now
again and it's not looking very good at
all right now for immortals one more to
go as the swing comes through but with
the Frisbee and steel
uh oh shorty what are you serious
Esperanza oh he does not care yeah I'll
just rush this down and the rest of the
team is doing much of the same also
unsuccessful like how is he doing this
with this [__] done
now as I said before the vast majority
of valorin's weapons are a direct copy
of Cs goes but obviously Wright wanted
to make sure that their game appealed to
a much wider audience than
Counter-Strike so they didn't completely
copy valve's creation instead they
wanted different weapons and play styles
to be viable and over the past three
years we've seen some of Riot's efforts
to differentiate themselves from
Counter-Strike come to fruition with
players building their entire Brands
around specific agents or weapons
outside of the status quo as a result
some teams in the space are known for
their measured methodical executes
others thrive on chaos and after the
not valorence three international
leagues we now have a sea of interesting
stats to look at and by we I mean Colton
because I am as sure as [__] not gonna
bore myself to death going through that
and now the guy who actually knows what
he's talking about this has to stop you
can't keep foisting these valorance
grips on me under the pretense of
Statistics I can see what you're doing
here
anyway the regular season for the VCT
America is wrapped up while we were
writing this video and
The League average for eco-round win
percentage was pretty crazy and for
those like me who didn't know eco-rounds
are awarded anytime a team wins around
while spending less than 10 000 credits
total with some help from Valor and
analyst willminder and stats from run it
back we know that the league average was
16.6 percent which is already pretty
high compared to what we saw in the
Champions stage at the Paris major but
one team stood out as a real anomaly in
the region Salvage here it's a phantom
in the handsome Jake like trying to get
a push out a shot long range does not
work out for BCG this is not looking
good at all it's a journey it's come by
himself standing ahead weapons are all
down Spike looks have been defused at
halfway and flanked the flick but it's
still do it again
Cloud9 boasted a 32 eco-round win rate
nearly double The League average they
actually had the best Thrifty round win
rate amongst all 30 VCT partner teams
worldwide the guard and specifically MCE
were often praised for their impressive
Eco rounds last year and that success
has definitely carried over to Cloud
Nine so how the hell are they this good
at Eco rounds I have no idea so we sat
down with zelsus zeppa and MCE to talk
about their Mastery of valorence
so-called weaker weapons having a
semblance of uh togetherness on things
where it's like three guys will set a
trap one guy will take an individual
duel one guy will hold so it's like
you're getting your chance at two or
three different points in rounds they do
a really good job of getting one and
getting out and I think what makes them
unique is like zeppa and leave uh even
zelsus at times they can kill multiple
people in one clip of the Stinger which
is not easy to do almost anyone can get
one kill with the Stinger every time
they can get two sometimes three kills
without reloading and that is like just
absolutely insane we always use a singer
the friends that you just you know
running running a gun and just like this
thing or just
hopefully they'll never Nerf it I mean
Stinger Stinger is like uh something
we've we've used before the Nerf and I
think because of like the the pre-nove
and how this how good the singer was
before the Nerf is like it was a pretty
like really good like a really easy to
handle and after the Nerf I mean
obviously like that's like a
more time to kill but it's kind of they
kept the pattern the same like how fast
the gun shoots like that so it's like
it's still basically the same gun if you
know how to use in the right situation
for sure but half buys
you know we're Stinger nine I don't know
what it is but I mean we like when we
see a stinger when we see a sheriff or
something we just take it a little bit
more seriously I feel like than most
than other people do you know like they
kind of get lazy or they don't really
respect it whereas like we take every
single gun every single game every
single round we take it like to the T
9 were so proficient with valorence
pistols and SMGs throughout the regular
season that they earn themselves the
second seed heading into playoffs a feat
literally nobody would have predicted
before VCT America's Got underway look
playing valorant maybe like pulling
teeth for me but even I can appreciate
just how impressive c9's Eco realm
prowess is the stats really are
extraordinary
even if their playoffs were not and that
was the guy who actually knows what he's
talking about so even if c9's eco-round
success was special it's still a lot
more doable and valorant than NCS and
depending on who you ask some people
might tell you that they don't like the
fact that nearly every single gun and
valorant is strong enough to do the job
especially most of us grizzled CS
players we enjoy knowing that our
economic Advantage can secure rounds and
that when we fall by we won't just get
obliterated by some [__] Zoomer
running us down with a judge or lasering
us with a stinger and although it might
not seem great from a competitive
standpoint if you ask a lot of the
valoran community they'll tell you that
they think that it adds a sort of depth
to the game
I don't think the guns should be nerfed
because I think what's
strangely interesting about Valerian is
that low-key and they've done it up
against every gun I mean is viable
shorty
the games are really good spot in my
opinion where there's a lot of variety
in ways you can play the game and what
you want to use inside the game all guns
having a specific use is kind of a cool
thing some might be a little overtuned
like I think the Marshall's a little bit
strong right now but uh everything else
has its individual use and rounds on
certain maps in certain areas and like
if you play to those strengths you see
you know success with it I honestly just
think they're fun
I I actually think like uh like our
because our team just likes to have fun
right like we're all like like trolley
people like we're serious obviously
right but when you know if you look down
to our personalities we're all kind of
just like clowns you know and I think
when you have like those like those
worse guns you're kind of just like I
mean they're like clown guns you know
they're not you know they're not the
Phantom the Vandal the off the Odin
whatever right they're just like they're
forced by like gimmick guns and I think
that's just like why we're so good with
them is like it kind of just fits our
personality we just like to have fun
with them and it just works for us so
sure you can argue that of course the
guys on C9 love the fact that all of the
guns are viable since they're the ones
using them to secure rounds but the
reality is that it's just valorent
functioning as intended these are
decisions that Riot made because they
wanted to appeal to a wider audience
instead of just the Aging hardcore
attack FPS fans that live and breathe Cs
and are fine with like seven guns being
viable but that's not to say that you
can't appreciate both you played you
play whichever game makes you happy and
it's okay to like both games anyone
tells you otherwise I'm trying to put a
foot forward don't believe them
comparing the two games is unfair
because they're just not made for the
same kind of gamer
good and valorant is part of what made
valorin popular in the first place and
helped it step out of Cs Go's Shadow you
don't see many players buying a Negev in
Pro play but you definitely see the
occasional Aries and that is a huge part
of valorence charm we've sat here for
years putting both games side by side
and comparing them but the reality is
that maybe they're not as similar as we
once thought
mm-hmm
[Music]
cool